in the last video we began to explore
the is curve which as i think i
mentioned stands for investment savings
and we really analyzed it from the point
of view of investment we were we
we thought of it as real interest rates
driving the level of investment which
drives the equilibrium level of real
output high real interest rates low
level of investment low level of
investment leads to low equilibrium
output so this scenario is closer to
that right over there if real interest
rates are lower then that leads to
higher levels of planned investment
which leads to a higher level of
equilibrium output so that right over
there what i want to do in this video so
that was from more from the investment
point of view what i want to do in this
video is explore the exact same
relationship the exact same curve but
think of it more from the savings point
of view and in this situation we're
going to have this exact same thing but
where instead of viewing real interest
rates as driving gdp we're actually
going to view gdp as driving real
interest rates and so let me leave this
up here but let's just let's just break
down the expenditure model of gdp
so we know that aggregate income or
aggregate gdp or aggregate output
however you want to think of it is equal
to into you could break it up into its
component expenditures it's equal to
aggregate consumer spending which is a
function of disposable income y minus t
is disposable income aggregate income
minus taxes
plus investment
plus investment plus government
expenditures
plus government expenditures and i could
do net exports but for simplicity for
this discussion we'll just assume we are
in a closed economy it makes
conceptualizing saving an investment a
little bit easier
now what i want to do is solve for
investment so if i solve for investment
i'm just going to subtract this piece
and this piece from both sides of this
equation and i get
aggregate income
minus
total
aggregate consumer spending
total aggregate consumer spending minus
total government spending is equal to on
the right hand side i'm just going to be
left with i'm just going to be left with
investment right over here
and this thing right over here is
interesting because this is total income
minus minus what let me make sure that
we i don't want to confuse you because
that looks like a lower kc and if we're
talking about aggregate consumption it's
usually an uppercase c
so on the left-hand side we have total
aggregate income minus consumer spending
minus government spending so you could
really view this as this right over here
really is aggregate savings
this over here really is savings and as
we see when on one side of the economy
when people are saving that goes into
banks and it gets lent out and that or
or and then it gets reinvested or you
could save directly by reinvesting and
so what we have here savings is equal to
investment and that's why it's called an
is curve because when you look at the
expenditure model savings and investment
are really the same thing they could
have they're really just saying look
there's two ways to view this curve it's
it's it's investment driven or it's
savings driven and when you think of it
this way you have a slightly different
view of this curve because when you view
it from a savings point of view you say
well what's going to happen if gdp goes
up what happens if we have a high if we
have a high gdp over here so if we have
a high gdp or let's say in particular
gdp
if gdp goes up
the consumer spending which is a
function of gdp it will go up but it
won't go up as much it's going to go up
by
this this expression right here times if
we assume a linear model times the
marginal propensity to consume which is
less than one it's between zero and 1.
so this is going to go up less than that
and then we can we're for the sake of
this model we'll assume right now that
that happens without any change in
government expenditure so if this if
total aggregate gd if total aggregate
income goes up then savings are going to
go up if we assume government
expenditures holds constant so then we
have savings
savings goes up
and if savings goes up that means we
have more loanable funds there's more
money to lend and if there's more money
to land what's going to happen to
interest rates well interest rates are
just the price of borrowing money the
price of money so if you have more of
something the price of that thing goes
down so if savings goes up then real
interest rates real interest rates go
down so if you have a high gdp you're
going to end up with low real interest
rates so once again it's looking at it
from a point of view of gdp driving
interest rates we have high savings here
so we're going to have low interest
rates and you view it the other way
around if you have a lower
if you have a lower income this thing is
going to also decrease but it's not
going to decrease as much as this did
because of the the marginal propensity
to consume is less than one we saw that
up here
we saw that all the way over here right
over there
and so in aggregate the savings are
going to go down once again we hold
government spending constant so in this
situation savings
savings are going to go down and if you
have fewer loanable funds there's less
savings to lend out then
if if you have a less of a supply of
something what's going to happen to its
price is price is going to go up the
price of borrowing money is the interest
rate so in this situation interest rates
would go up so that's going in this
direction right over here if aggregate
income goes down loanable funds go down
interest rates are going to be higher so
once again same exact curve is curve but
there's two takeaways here one is to
realize why it's called is that
investment in savings when you view it
from this point of view really are the
same thing one person's savings can be
another person's investment and when we
viewed it from the investment point of
view we were viewing r as driving y now
we're looking at the other way around y
is driving savings which is driving r
but it gives us the exact same
relationship for this model